[Musique]
arthur clarke a déjà dit que la
technologie à un certain point
c'est aussi impressionnant que la magie
semaine de la magie et il est totalement
raison en fait tant de choses qu'on
prend pour acquise aujourd'hui aurait
paru magique à nos arrières grands
parents
le problème c'est qu'on a souvent
tendance à penser que cette magie l'oeil
et seulement les chercheurs que les
grandes corporations qui peuvent la
craie et qu'on peut rien changer
c'était certainement mon cours
secondaire j'étais fasciné par la
science je voyais un moyen de comprendre
le monde assouvir la curiosité mais
rapidement j'ai eu envie de plus que
seulement à prendre
moi aussi je voulais contribuer à créer
cette magie bon le système scolaire j'ai
bien fait mais il laisse peu de place à
l'exploration
on peut pas vraiment vouloir à nos
professeurs qui ont plusieurs dizaines
d'élèves à gérer énormément de contenu à
couvrir au cours de l'année et même les
travaux les plus libres sont
généralement noté ce qui décourage
l'exploration débridée les idées
novatrices au profit de projets plus ou
moins d'avoir des bons résultats au plus
de bien performer les choses plus
simples bref aujourd'hui je suis à
l'université et j'ai la chance d'étudier
certains de ces domaines qui paraissent
magique même pour les chercheurs qui
travaillent à tous les jours et une ces
domaines c'est l'informatique quantique
qui est une branche de la physique
quantique que pour but d'essayer de
pousser les limites actuelles des
ordinateurs bond à ses programmes
demandé tout d'abord qu'est-ce que la
physique quantique
pour faire simple la physique quantique
et la physique qui étudie le domaine de
l'infiniment petit
donc les atomes et les molécules comparé
à la physique classique on la physique
traditionnelle qui est enseigné au
secondaire qui étudie les domaines qu'on
voit dans la vie de tous les jours
les doigts de 10 physique confié vous en
doutez sont différentes entre la
physique classique et la physique
quantique et apporte un tout autre
univers de possibilités dont les
ordinateurs quantiques
donc j'imagine votre prochaine question
probablement et pourquoi on a besoin
d'un ordinateur quantique
à quoi ça sert
et j'imagine que plusieurs d'entre vous
seront familiers avec la loi de moore
qui est une loi informelle selon
laquelle chaque plus ou moins deux ans
la grosseur d'un transistor diminue de
moitié ce qui fait qu'on peut remettre
deux fois plus dans les ordinateurs et
donc doubler leur puissance de calcul si
on sait qu'on est passé il y a vingt ans
de gros ordinateurs aujourd'hui avoir
des ordinateurs beaucoup plus performant
dans notre poche en tout temps mais
pendant fond comme vous vous en doutez
évident éventuellement il ya une limite
à la grosseur que le transit on peut
avoir dans les ordinateurs récents la
grosseur des princes temps red à peu
près 14 nanomètres 14 nanomètres c'est
14 milliards diem de m donc extrêmement
petit mais il ya déjà des transistors
deux chaînes de nouvelles quand j'étais
construit ce qui est à peu près 10 fois
plus gros qu'une atomes d'hydrogène donc
extrêmement petit
éventuellement on va arriver à un stade
où on pourra plus réduire la taille et
la sq il faut seulement se donner une
tape dans le dos arrêter la recherche de
félicitations on est arrivé au bout
bien sûr que non l'humain est une espèce
curieuse on veut toujours faire mieux et
donc les chercheurs en s'approchant
toujours plus du domaine de l'infiniment
petit son arrivée a observé des
phénomènes de physique quantique dans
les ordinateurs est plutôt que d'essayer
de les combattre
ils ont essayé de les utiliser de les
exploiter et c'est comme ça qu'est né le
premier ordinateur quantique
alors bon caisse comment ça fonctionne
pourquoi c'est intéressant et comment ça
fonctionne et bien il ya deux propriétés
de la physique quantique qui sont
responsables pour la puissance de ses
ordinateurs nouveau genre alors la
première et la superposition quantique
c'est une propriété qui suivant mais
compris mais qui au fond maintenant est
très simple donc dans des danses
physique classique
les particules non seulement un état en
transitant par exemple dans un sénateur
peut être soit 1 0 s'il n'ya pas de
courant électrique dans le transit en
soie or si un courant électrique dans
transit en évitant évidemment il peut
pas avoir à la fois pas de courant
électrique et un courant électrique en
physique quantique c'est la même chose
la seule différence est que de par la
nature des atomes et des molécules les
probabilités et les différentes options
sont représentés par des probabilités
donc peut-être que dans 50 % des cas
un courant électrique pendant que dans
50 % des cols du tour électrique et
c'est en faisant des calculs sur ces
probabilités que les ordinateurs qu'on
en tire une grande partie de leur
pouvoir
donc tant qu'on n'a pas observé tant
qu'on ne peut vérifier qu'elle est
réellement la situation avec les
transistors
on estime qu'ils aient dans une
superposition des deux états donc dans
certains cas il va être avoir un courant
électrique être un et dans certains cas
il ya pas de quoi intriguer 21 0 c'est
le concept de superposition avec le
fameux chat de schrödinger qui est à la
fois mort et vivant
bon évidemment vous en doutez un seul
transistors n'est pas très utile et
c'est avec plusieurs transitoire que le
concept de superposition de pendant
d'intrication quanti qu'apparaît alors
l'intrication quantique c'est un bien
grand mot mais fondamentalement ce que
ça veut dire c'est que au lieu d'exister
de manière autonome les particules
existe en faisant partie d'un tout donc
alors que dans une ossature classique
chaque nouveau transistor peut interagir
avec quelques transistors rapprocher ans
nordine en informatique quantique chaque
transitant peut interagir avec tous les
transistors faisant partie de
l'ordinateur fonctionne non seulement
aux transistors
on a deux pros pris deux possibilités
soit 1,0 soit 1
par contre sur le 2 transistors
maintenant on a quatre possibles et à 0
0 0 1 1 0 et entre un bon et c'est ce
qui crée en fait une propriété de
croissance exponentielle c'est à dire
que je suis plus chaque fois qu'on
double la quantité transistors ont qu
une brouille de croissance exponentielle
dans la puissance des ordinateurs et
c'est ce qui leur donne la majorité de
la puissance bon probablement que vous
demandez bon qu'est ce que ça change
pour moi la vraie question vraiment et
qu'en dise que je vais bright food
cantiques tandis que je vais pouvoir
aller sur facebook super vite et la
réponse malheureusement est probablement
jamais c'est pas vraiment l'utilité des
ordinateurs quantiques
alors que dans les ordinateurs
classiques et plusieurs propriétés qu'on
utilise dans la vie de tous les jours
les ordinateurs quantiques sont très
performants sur certaines tranches en
particulier donc par exemple en chimie
en médecine de par leur capacité à
simuler des molécules et simuler des
médicaments ou en cyber sécurité pour
faire du cryptage de données ou en
intelligence
spécial mais vraiment dans la vie de
tous les jours il ya pas une très grande
amélioration par rapport à les orateurs
classique donc inquiétez-vous voir les
autres acteurs que vous avez acheté
aujourd'hui vont encore être utile dans
le futur et probable que vous vous
demandez dans ce cas là si ça change
rien dans ma vie de tous les jours et
c'est il faut être un doctorat en
physique pour pouvoir contribuer qu'est
ce que ça change pour moi à quoi ça sert
d'en savoir un peu plus et quand j
mentionnait que j'allais parler
d'informatique quantique plusieurs
personnes vont poser cette question se
demandait à quoi ça sert
pourquoi je devrais m'en préoccuper si
ça va pas m'affecter directement si si
je voulais vraiment contribué il y
aurait fallu que je fasse des longues
études en physique des longues études en
en informatique je devienne chercheurs
que je sois parmi les plus brillants sur
la planète est en fait la réalité est
tout autre
- vous les chercheurs aujourd'hui n'ont
pour la plupart pas accès à un
ordinateur quantique de plusieurs
compagnies dont microsoft ou ibm qui
possèdent des ordinateurs quantiques
disponibles pour la recherche et qu'il y
met disponibles sur internet pour
quiconque eu le désir de contribuer
c'est d'ailleurs sur ces ordinateurs
look et la plupart des travaux de
recherche universitaires sont
performants on peut en voir un ici
quiconque avec le désir de contribuer
avec le désir de découvrir ces domaines
à peu aller sur leur site web commencé à
suivre le tutoriel est à prendre au
domaine de l'informatique quantique et
performer leurs propres expériences sur
ses ordinateurs
donc chaque jour il ya des milliers de
curieux et curieuses du parieur de
familiale étudiant en secondaire aux
chercheurs universitaires qui vont sur
ces sites là et font leurs propres
expériences et contribuer à faire
avancer un domaine la séance qui est
pour potentiel de radicalement
influencer la société dans un avenir
assez rapproché
en fait c'est une période très excitante
pour l'informatique quantique à ibm et
google deux des plus grands chercheurs
d'une compagnie que les plus grands
chercheurs dans le domaine estime que
d'ici 2020
ils vont arriver à construire un
ordinateur quantique qui sera plus
performant que le meilleur super
ordinateur actuellement disponible sa
parodie
j'étais très très importante en médecine
et en chimie peut nous permettre de
mieux comprendre énormément de maladie
c'est quelque chose auquel j'ai
personnellement eu la chance de
contribuer et c'est quelque chose auquel
vous aussi pouvez contribuer si vous le
désirez vous voyez quand j'étais au
secondaire je rêvais de pouvoir
contribuer à ce genre de projet mais
j'étais convaincu qu'il fallait un
doctorat qu'il fallait avoir énormément
d'argent puis être einstein de ce monde
pour pour contribuer à l'informatique
quantique loi quelconque domaine de la
science mais la réalité est tout autre
la science est beaucoup plus accessible
qu'on le pense que ce soit pour
l'informatique quantique ou n'importe
quel autre branche des sciences
la plupart des progrès sont faits par
des gens normaux ou des chercheurs qui
sont pas forcément parmi les meilleurs
dans leur domaine mais qui ont la
curiosité intellectuelle désir de
persévérer puis de comprendre le monde
qui nous entoure
et puis vous savez si tout le monde dans
cette salle puis plus de gens contribuer
au développement de la science peut être
qu'ici aussi on aurait une propriété de
croissance exponentielle sur le
développement de nouvelles technologies
et puis qui sait peut-être ferez-vous la
prochaine grande découverte
merci
[Applaudissements]